it's tailgate season in America and I'm
tired of Iran just ordering burgers on
their phone so I'm putting the challenge
out there to Mir to see what she can
come up with in just 10 minutes
Mir don't disappoint welcome to Ramsay
and 10 hi guys I'm Mia Castro I'm the
challenge Queen from house kitchen today
Gordon challenged me to make a burger in
under 10 minutes so I'm making my
version of a tailgate turkey burger with
an avocado spread and I'm adding some
potato sticks for a little bit of crunch
too so like any good football
competition Gordon you're on let's start
so right here I have some ground turkey
what I like to add - turkey burger is
because sometimes they end up being on
the dry side is some zucchini to keep
them moist and I'm just gonna grate it
right into here and if you don't have
one of these at home you can just use a
box grater or kind of just like rough
chop it yourself and I have some pre
chopped garlic I have some smoked
paprika and I like using this because it
gives food that sort of like ham or
bacon flavor we're gonna try to add as
much flavor as we can into the meat
everyone needs to chill out
on measuring I just I throw things in
there and you can just taste it as you
go take a little piece of burger throw
it on the grill taste it if it needs
more add more some salt
stir that up and if you're having people
over for game day you can just make
these patties ahead of time so when you
have your guests over all you have to do
is throw them on the grill or on the pan
we don't really watch that much football
in Puerto Rico at least my family did it
but for any game day like if it's a
boxing match or for us it's actually the
Miss Universe pageant then I look
pre-boil the pan real quick because I'm
about to use my hands so the thinner the
patty the faster its gonna cook it's
really up to you how thick you want it
turnip root Gordon right though so I
want to finish this in 10 minutes
[Music]
when you get the burger on you want to
make sure that your feet is on
medium-high I like it when it gets kind
of crispy around it and that's why I
actually preferred turkey burgers to
beef burgers you want a list of
ingredients just check the description
for less while that's cooking I'm gonna
make a quick sauce with avocados and
this is a good substitution for
mayonnaise and cheese that way you don't
feel like crap after you eat a burger
sorry this is cooperating if the pits
not cooperating just take it out with a
fork but these knives are so sharp
they're cutting through the pit good do
you actually even use your knife here
they're so sharp we're still good I got
this Gordon
it suggests a little bit of salt some
lemon juice this is something else that
you can pre make ahead of time and a
little bit of olive oil then just mash
it up with a fork all right so don't
forget your burger oil it on top again
we're gonna toast our patties now get a
little bit of butter on there so it gets
a really good fruit of brown color I
actually like to season the buns a
little bit so you actually taste the
butter
right now I think we're gonna make it
Gordon one nice slice of tomato and you
can top it with whatever you want these
are just my favorite things
[Music]
oh so I'm getting the lettuce flat so it
covers the bun really nice and I get two
pieces on there I like to put it in the
bottom so that the juice from the turkey
burgers doesn't make the bun soggy going
with Turkey right on top so you know if
it's done by kind of poking it in the
middle and if it feels firm it's ready
to go let's check our bun perfect I like
to season my tomato
it's getting really close now these
avocados could have ruined me I think I
still have it and magic touch Bobby does
get a lot of them on there that's what
makes it really good and time is ticking
so I got to get the Sun there we go
oh my god I think that was just ten
minutes Gordon you almost happened there
you go
tailgate turkey burgers in ten minutes
reporting Tony side around team 10/10
commentary Abajo and okay pensaron de
l'homme briganza
he not being so creamy say al canal de
chef Gordon Ramsay and YouTube for those
of you that didn't catch up thank you
for watching Ramsay and ten don't forget
to subscribe to a Gordon's YouTube
channel and leave a comment below
[Music]